so one day there's gonna be not very
soon did you make any plans you have
plans right of course I made plans I
made the best plans we're gonna
challenge each other to see who is the
best youtuber in the couple we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna play best fans
so you will level up the most in a
week-long contest well then you have
nothing to be afraid of well then the
winner will be taken out for dinner by
the loser all right fine
yeah it's a deal all right so you guys
can help us out whichever you want to
think should win by giving us support
points yeah so challenge your
significant other it could be
boyfriend-girlfriend mom hat whatever
you want whoever wins can choose to give
a support point and it could be as you
like but it should be to me
so to submit your support point tweet a
picture to me don't plug your Twitter
but make sure you do it at 3:00 p.m.
before it closes February the 13th then
I say that right est don't come hi
I've traveled far from the future to
tell you two things because these idiots
forgot number one best fans you can
download it I'll leave a link to it in
the description check it out number two
so we can find your supporter points
post either in the hash tag team Marzia
or hash tag team foods with your picture
destroying your opponent so we can find
it that way all right that is all I will
now return to the land of fabulous Oh
if I lose against my girlfriend it's
gonna make me look bad
oh you're so gonna lose it's like
written already thank you for watching
this video like I'm enjoy it and we'll
see you in the future of the space
double brofist